now we'll explore the use case for SQL
managed services
but first let's revisit what a database
is and how it's used
a database is a collection of
information that's organized so that it
can easily be accessed and managed
users are building software applications
using databases to answer business
questions such as buying a ticket filing
an expense report storing a photo or
storing medical records
Computer Applications run databases to
get a fast answer to questions like
what's this user's name given their
sign-in information so I can display it
what's the cost of product y so I can
show it on my Dynamic web page
what were my top 10 best-selling
products this month
and what's the next ad that I should
show the user currently browsing my site
these apps must be able to write data in
and read data out of databases
when a database is used it's usually run
by a computer application
so when we say that a database is useful
for doing X it's usually because it's
designed to make answering a question
simple fast and efficient for the app
relational database Management Systems
abbreviated to rdbms or just relational
databases are used extensively under the
kind of database you encounter most of
the time
they're organized based on the
relational model of data
they're very good when you have a
well-structured data model and when you
need transactions and the ability to
join data across tables to retrieve
complex combinations of your data
because they make use of the structured
query language they're sometimes called
SQL databases
Google Cloud offers two managed
relational database services
Cloud SQL and Cloud spanner let's
explore each of them in detail